my name is Jim Conda jr. I'm running in
the eighth District of Ohio for the US
House of Representatives running against
John Boehner who's the speaker of the
house I look at the United States is now
in a battle for what the future is going
to be about the United States and John
Boehner is probably went to Washington
with high hopes like mr. Smith goes to
Washington but he got sucked into the
Washington power structure
people believe if you're being heard
through the big radio stations through
the big TV station that you are a
serious candidate in some way and if
they just see you're walking around
passing a letter and shaking hand I
think they wonder if you're a fringe
fringe nut too just as you know doing it
for some ego trip or something you know
yes i would like to win but you know
being outspent maybe seven million
dollars a few thousand dollars that was
not realistic the biggest challenges to
raise money to be in the game
want more download the aj+ mobile app
and join the conversation available in
your app store now